Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie!
This is going to be my new Batman HBO series
video we have some amazing news about what's
going on with the world of Robert Pattinson
and Matt Reeves Batman on HBO.
We'll break it all down is all good news.
If you're new to the channel.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything of
course I'll do episode videos for all the
episodes when it eventually winds up premiering
is all talk about what's going on with this
what it would involve and how it's tied to
what's going on with the new Batman movies
starting with number five this morning.
If you didn't see the news Warner Bros. announced
that they were making of Batman HBO series,
not the one you expected either because there's
been a lot of talk about Batman HBO series
the past couple of weeks is a Batman HBO series
set in the world of Matt Reeves and Robert
Pattinsons the Batman movie that's happening
next year Matt Reeves issued a couple statements
clarifying what is going to be who's going
to involve I know there's all kinds of questions
like how many episodes is a going to be what
is he going to premiere will Robert Robert
Pattinsons show up as the Batman.
How will they differentiate those Batman stories
from the story that they cover in the Batman
trilogy of movies that they're making with
Robert Pattinsons and same goes for all the
major Batman villains that are already appearing
in the Batman movies like the Penguin Catwoman
the regular and obviously the new version
the Joker who we learned a little while ago
will eventually show up in the Batman movie
sequels.
Civilized people first things first though
we can all breathe a sigh of relief the not
gonna try and do this on some terrible network
where they have to water it down into 23 episodes
of season with a ton of filler low-budget
this is HBO were talking about we been dreaming
about an HBO Batman series for years every
time you hear about a new Batman spinoff character
or Batman stuff happening on TV the DC TV
universe.
We all just say just give us a Batman TV show
on HBO.
It would be amazing everybody would watch
it, but this brand-new Matt Reeves Batman
HBO series doesn't include the news about
all the potential Batman villain spinoff solo
movies because the way they're engineering
the Batman movies.
It seems like he really is creating a new
self-contained Batman universe for himself
at DC that is not necessarily closely tied
to what's going on with all the Justice league
DC EU stuff and make a little more sense when
you see how the Batman TV show the doing on
HBO is connected to the movies.
Number four.
Here's Matt Reeves official statement about
the series.
So he says this is an amazing opportunity
not only to expand the vision of the world.
I'm creating in the film talk about the Batman
2021 movie, but to explore in the kind of
depth and detail that only longform format
can afford.
Then he goes on to say, and getting to work
with the incredibly talented Terrence winter
who has written so insightfully and powerfully
about worlds of crime and corruption is an
absolute dream our collaboration with Warner
Bros. and DC allows us to elaborate and grow
fan connections across these powerful brands
talk about HBO Max in the movies for years
to come.
This is Batman, as most audiences have never
seen before and we know fans will want to
spend more time in this new world inspired
by the movie, so the fact that Matt Reeves
is saying that is more of an expansion of
the world that is creating for the Batman
in the movies and not just inspired by it
is key here it means to live here much more
closely to the characters the look in the
story that we see in the movie is not gonna
be some crazy prequel twist where it's a young
version of Robert Pattinsons and is Batman
before he became Batman and he said in present
day with a lot of the characters that we see
in the movies so the TV show will be connected
to the movies the Batman movies with Robert
Pattinsons and at least.
And there will be crossover Marvel is doing
the exact same thing with his Avengers spinoff
Disney plus series.
For example Avengers endgame happens Captain
America gives falcon the shield.
The events of the falcon winter soldier series
starring both of them from the movie and a
lot of other movie characters will follow
the events of what happens next with that
part of the Avengers back in the world of
DC we have the HBO Green Lantern series coming
up now I'm actually kind of assuming that
their strategy overall with these big-budget
HBO series for DC is the most of them will
wind up connecting with the movies and crossover
in some kind of way.
So, for instance, they're doing HBO Green
Lantern series.
We know a lot about the plot of that and who
the characters are going to be with her also
still making a Green Lantern Corps movie my
assumption now is the HBO Green Lantern series
will have something to do with the eventual
Green Lantern Corps movie, they just announced
the Justice league dark series the JJ Abrams
is doing with bad robot, but we haven't heard
too much about what's going on with that.
There's also a Justice league dark movie that
they're developing, so it sounds like the
Justice league dark series will also cross
over and connect with the Justice league dark
movie, so it's a little easier to understand
what Warner Bros. strategy is for their HBO
DC series, number three next big question
about this new Batman series.
Who's going to be the main villain of season
one.
So since the Batman 20, 21 movie is adapting
portions of the long Halloween for it storyline
and Carmine Falcone.
He is heavily featured during that my early
prediction is that the main villain of the
HBO series in season one will probably be
someone from the Gotham city mob there's a
ton of big mob characters in the world of
Batman comics, Oconee himself winds up getting
killed by the main villain of the long Halloween
during that story, so I don't know if that
means that is also going to die during the
events of the Batman movie next year.
If you read the story.
Please don't post big spoilers about who the
real villain of that story is because it is
a big twist and I don't know how much Matt
Reeves change that storyline for the actual
movie it's knocking to be a straight up long
Halloween movie will be exactly like the comic
book story, but is very much a murder mystery
outside of Batman himself.
They didn't say who the main characters would
be either is like a Gotham city Central series.
So Jim Gordon would arguably be one of the
main characters at least this is all starting
to feel kind of familiar to to some of you
owe yet then we just have a Gotham city police
show on Fox a couple years ago I guess now
we found out why they decided to cancel it
when they did before they got to hard-core
Batman stuff, number two.
If you never watched it Gotham on Fox was
basically a cop show with Gordon in a young
Bruce Wayne is the main characters David Mrs.
play the young Bruce Wayne in the series basically
started the moment after his parents were
killed in crime Allie that was literally the
beginning of episode one.
They did that show is more of a Batman prequel
series set before he leaves got them to wander
the world train with the league of assassins
and Ray shall cool although they did do most
of Batman's core villains on the show in some
form, including a version of Ray shall cool
played by Alexander Citic.
I feel like the show started out really promising
because raw like oh they're finally doing
Batman stuff on TV, but ultimately I kind
of bailed on the show after he got a little
too ridiculous in little too campy.
It almost felt like they were going into Joel
Schumacher George Clooney Batman territory
at times with the performances.
It was kind of low budget and they waited
till the finale the series finale to actually
put Batman in a Batman costume.
This is what that looked like.
So just sounds like now the HBO Batman series
that they're doing based on Robert Pattinsons
is Batman will fix a lot of those issues with
them doing Batman on TV you would like a big
budget miniseries, so it feels more like a
long movie less like an actual TV show.
Number one, though.
They haven't listed an actual premier date,
but given the virus delays in filming schedules
and what's going on with the Batman movie
right now that they're still in the middle
of filming.
I'm assuming they're gonna trying it out by
2022, so that means they will start releasing
episodes between Batman movie sequels.
They haven't officially green lit the Batman
movie SQL yet, like the Batman two or whatever
you want to call it but I think it's safe
to assume that that's gonna get made and since
this is HBO were talking about.
This means huge budget also probably means
it'll only be 8 to 10 episodes per season
which personally I think is actually better
than doing a super low budget series, and
just cranking out a ton of filler episodes
like a lot of the CW DC TV shows do just give
us quality over quantity just give us a really
awesome version of this Batman universe on
TV and everyone will be happy but hopefully
this puts to rest those Ben Affleck Batman
HBO rumors there a lot of Ben Affleck Batman
fans who thought that he was coming back for
more Batman after the Justice league Snyder
cut since it's Matt Reeves Batman this getting
all this HBO stuff that means the only Ben
Affleck on HBO that you're going to see is
in the Snyder cut and potentially in the suicide
squad a year cut if they do wind up doing
that and obviously this new Batman TV series
stuff has nothing to do with Michael Keaton's
Batman that's coming back for the DC movies.
If he wound up doing a Batman series on HBO.
I would hope that it would actually be a Batman
beyond spinoff series for Terry McGinnis character
after Batman beyond movie only then that Michael
Keaton was signing on for multiple Batman
appearances.
It was implied that one of those would be
a Batman beyond movie, so the odds of them
doing Batman beyond as an HBO series and say
like 4 to 5 years just shot up a thousand
percent for those either really hoping for
live-action Batman beyond is a very good time
to be a Batman fan everyone just let me know
in the comments.
What you think about this what you hope that
they're doing with these HBO Batman series.
Congratulations to write Ribiltion Jones your
the giveaway winner from my last big DC video.
Please email me on the about page my channel
so I can get your contact details everyone
click here for the Batman 2021 trailer video
and Easter eggs and click here for that brand-new
Justice league Snyder cut trailer thank you
so much for watching everyone stay safe
I'll see you guys tonight!